john carpenter and horror films go
together like michael myers and a big
kitchen knife but if you dive deep into
his filmography you'll find a
surprisingly eclectic body of work
populated with sci-fi comedies space
voyage parodies alien romances and even
a musical biopic
in 1995 carpenter released village of
the damned
a remake of the 1960 sci-fi horror
classic of the same name
about a strange group of children born
out of a supernatural event who then
began to hold their small town hostage
with psychic abilities and an apparent
lack of humanity
the film features an ensemble cast that
includes christopher reeve mark hamill
kirstie alley meredith salinger and more
along with plenty of spooky atmosphere
courtesy of carpenter's ever-present
widescreen camera
let's be clear village of the damned may
be at the bottom of this list but it is
by no means a terrible film
it's got buckets of atmosphere a
compelling cast and when the spooky kids
are doing their spooky kid stuff it
sucks you in
that said the film is among carpenter's
slowest moving endeavors
it seems to creep from horror beat to
four beats in the worst way
leaving long stretches where the viewer
is less than compelled carpenter once
said village of the damned was a film he
wasn't particularly passionate about
making
revisiting it all these years later it
shows
ghosts of mars one of carpenter's last
directorial efforts to date is the story
of a group of police officers on mars in
a future where humanity has terraformed
the red planet and set up a society
there
the cops are just supposed to be picking
up a notorious prisoner for transport
but when they arrive at their
destination
they find that ancient martian spirits
have emerged to possess every human in
sight and they have no choice but to
fight their way out
it's basically assault on precinct 13
with space ghost and while that's fun in
some form no matter how you slice it
ghost of mars is never
quite as fun as it seems to think it is
carpenter was aiming for deliberate
sci-fi action camp with this film and he
definitely hits his mark more often than
not
the trouble is that the campy tropes
often repeat themselves the film's
visual effects can't rise to the
occasion and even the intentionally over
the top stuff doesn't always register
that way
that's beautiful the result is an uneven
but fun little sci-fi thriller that
while far from carpenter's best is still
worth seeing for the frequent
appearances of martian ghost who seem to
be followed by heavy metal guitars
everywhere they go
john carpenter's latest directorial
effort to date is this period horror
piece about a group of girls in a mental
institution who are stalked by a
supernatural killer the ward was
released in 2010 but it retains a
certain timeless quality
the setting is straightforward enough
that carpenter could have made it at any
point in his career
the atmospheric photography and pacing
are classic and they make the film worth
seeking out for
fans of the master unfortunately the
atmosphere is not enough to overcome the
ward's formulaic story which builds to a
twist that not only has been done before
in other horror films but done
better even if the twist did land in a
more satisfying way the film also lacks
the fine strokes of character building
that carpenter executed so well and some
of his better work
so the film's resolution doesn't pay off
as well as it could have
that said the central antagonist of the
film is decidedly creepy and when the
ward is in full scare mode it's clear
that carpenter hasn't lost the step in
that department
between halloween and the fog carpenter
took a couple of gigs as a tv movie
director and of those two elvis is the
most ambitious
released less than two years after the
king of rock and roll's death the film
has an epic look at elvis presley's life
from his childhood up until the
beginning of his las vegas era
starring in the title role is kurt
russell marking the beginning of his
long collaboration with carpenter
though it perhaps feels out of place
amid his most famous films carpenter is
no less gifted when it comes to telling
the story of elvis presley
and it certainly helped matters that he
had someone as charismatic as russell
leading the way
elvis works is what it is which is a
very straightforward made-for-tv biopic
with a few kinks that are never quite
ironed out
these days it might only be sought out
by elvis superfans and carpenter
completionist but the director did his
job and he did it well
carpenter's other major tv movie gig in
the late 1970s was this straightforward
thriller about a live tv director who
takes a new job in los
angeles she moves into a sleek new
high-rise apartment building
only to find that she's also attracted a
terrifying new stalker in the process
i'll find you i don't give up
carpenter has been compared to albert
hitchcock in terms of the way he builds
and releases tension and someone's
watching me might be the most
straightforward showcase of his
hitchcockian gifts in his entire
filmography
the film plays in some places like a
riff on rear window and carpenter's
screenplay is full of the kind of witty
banter that you could easily imagine
someone like grace kelly or tippy hedren
rattling off
it's also chalk full of tension and the
lead performances from lauren hutton and
adrian barbeau are consistently
compelling
it's not as flashy or ambitious as
carpenter's best work but someone's
watching me still works as a
well-executed tv thriller
there aren't a lot of sequels in john
carpenter's filmography perhaps because
of his bad experience with trying to
deliver follow-ups to halloween in the
late 1970s and early 80s
but 15 years after escape from new york
hit theaters carpenter decided to return
to that post-apocalyptic world and its
eye-patch-clad hero snake pliskin
escape from la is set 16 years after the
original and follows snake as he has
once again offered a shot at freedom if
he's willing to help the united states
government by completing a near
impossible mission with a ticking clock
this time around he's sent into los
angeles which has become an island
thanks to an earthquake years earlier
and which has been transformed into
another prison wasteland thanks to a new
president who has ushered in a theocracy
the film works best when carpenter is
playing in the new sandbox of ambitious
dystopian ideas he's built for himself
but the film never quite coalesces in
the way that its predecessor did
this is insane it is
that's the point there are a lot of
interesting things happening in this
movie and russell is charismatic as ever
but it suffers by virtue of being a
sequel to one of the great cult sci-fi
films
if any carpenter film deserves the title
of most underrated it might be memoirs
of an invisible man
a movie that seems to have been all but
forgotten amid carpenter's more high
profile efforts but deserves to be
remembered
the film stars chevy chase as nick a
stock analyst whose life is upended when
he goes to a shareholders meeting at a
tech firm and as the result of an
accident wakes up to find himself
invisible
with a government agent on his trail and
a new love interest wondering what
happened to him nick has to figure out
how to adjust to life as an unseen
presence
though it suffers from a lot of
formulaic story beats carpenter is
clearly having fun
spinning a noir influence tale of a man
recounting his own zany sci-fi
adventures and chase pours a
considerable amount of screen presence
into his performance
even when you can't see him throw in
some wonderful and very playful visual
effects and memoirs of an invisible man
is a sci-fi comedy that deserves to be
seen by more people
carpenter's first feature film is this
strange sci-fi spoof from 1974
which began as a student film and later
evolved into a theatrically released
effort that remains impressive in its
ingenuity and comedic sensibility
co-written by carpenter and dan o'bannon
darkstar follows the crew of the titular
starship on a long-term mission into
deep space where everything seems to be
going wrong
um the planet just exploded sir
dark star is a parody of ponderous
sci-fi fiction fair like 2001 a space
odyssey
as a result plot points include
everything from a commander in cryogenic
stasis as a result of an accident to an
artificially intelligent bomb that keeps
trying to drop itself out of the ship
and detonate due to an error
it drags in places and certainly plays
as amateurish on others but you can see
the talent at work here
it's not just good for a student film
it's genuinely fun inventive and
subversive
the long story of how starman finally
made it to screen is almost as
interesting as the film itself which
follows a widow who encounters an alien
being who assumes the form of her late
husband upon arriving on earth
the film went through various
permutations and numerous directors on
its way to the screen
by the time carpenter got a hold of it
he was eager to make a film that allowed
him to break out of the particular genre
mold he'd worked himself into by the
mid-1980s and saw star man as an
opportunity to do a cross-country love
story with sci-fi elements
the result is a slow-burning beautifully
photographed film that allows carpenter
to do things like portray the majesty of
the country and mine the seemingly
infinite charm karen allen can convey
with a single smile
it's far from the most thrilling thing
carpenter ever produced but he did what
he set out to do
star man is a warm lingering sci-fi love
story anchored by two compelling stars
john carpenter is at his best when he's
working with a killer conceptual hook
and vampires is another example of that
it's far from his best high concept
genre flick but when this mean little
movie about vampire hunters and a master
blood drinker intent on ending the world
is really cooking
it's among carpenters most fun outings
the film follows master vampire hunter
jack crow and his crew of vatican
sanctioned slayers as they try to root
out a master vampire who's angling to
perform an
ancient ritual that will blot out the
sun forever turning earth into a
vampire's paradise
the film kicks off as crow and his team
are raiding a vampire nest
establishing the rules of the game and
then we get to watch as carpenter
methodically dismantles everything we
think we know about how this game is
played
it's part horror film and part western
showdown and while it doesn't pack the
same level of tension and emotional
investment as his best work vampires is
still a blast to watch
do you like creepshow do you like john
carpenter do you ever wish
john carpenter had directed some of
creep show if so
body bags is definitely for you
[Music]
carpenter and fellow horror legend toby
hooper teamed up for this comedy horror
anthology film which aired on showtime
in 1993
and the result is a fun collection of
spooky stories that's pretty much
carpenter's version of creepshow in a
very good way
carpenter directed two of the film's
three segments the gas station and hair
and also starred as the coroner a master
of ceremonies in the vein of the crypt
keeper who introduces the segments from
a morgue where he's working late
though it displays a predictable
unevenness between the various segments
body bags is an immensely fun look at
what happens when two horror masters get
together with some of their friends
including cameos from wes craven roger
corman sam raimi and more and
essentially just get to goof off with a
handful of scary stories
in halloween carpenter played with the
idea of an academic who'd come to the
conclusion that evil was a real tangible
thing that couldn't be reasoned with or
effectively analyzed
prince of darkness the second film in
carpenter's apocalypse trilogy
is an effort to further explore the same
idea as well as carpenter's fascination
with the intersection of faith and
science
the film follows a group of academics
who were brought into a church to
examine a strange cylinder that
purportedly contains the physical
embodiment of satan
as the film progresses they slowly
become aware that the evil within the
container is real
and that it wants out prince of darkness
is packed with intense horror moments
from a man dissolving into a pile of
insects to a woman transforming into the
embodiment of evil on earth
it's one of carpenter's best exercises
in pure terror and one of his most
ambitious
christine is to date the only time that
john carpenter's storytelling
sensibilities have met up with stephen
kings and the result is a horror classic
christine is as fans will know the name
of a car that a young man named arnie
cunningham buys against the advice of
everyone in his life
look i'm buying her i don't care what
you say
you're funeral man as arnie begins to
fix up the car he becomes obsessed with
it and christine starts to take on a
mind of her own
so christine is the haunted car movie
which means the movie doesn't work if
you can't create
a world in which the car is truly scary
carpenter pulls it off through late
night scenes of the driverless christine
ripping through the streets to run down
her victims
and through some unforgettable visual
effects which further drive home the
supernatural prowess of this beautiful
and deadly machine
christine is a slasher movie on wheels
and in a world where so many high
concepts that work on paper fail on the
big screen
this time that's actually as good as it
sounds
after nailing the slasher movie with
halloween in 1978
carpenter and his creative partner
deborah hill turned to ghost stories for
the next feature film
the result was the fog co-written by
hill and carpenter with hill also acting
as producer while carpenter directed
the fog is in many ways a classic
vengeful spirit story
documenting the supernatural terrors
that befall the town of antonio bay on
its 100th anniversary
the day it also happens to be the 100th
anniversary of a great injustice upon
which the town was founded
while the vengeful spirit side of things
is a bit formulaic carpenter knocks it
out of the park with the atmospherics
from the opening minutes of the film in
which paranormal events start slowly
creeping into town ahead of the fog to
the terrifying climax featuring a band
of rotting ghosts and church
the fog is a beautifully shot small town
nightmare with a fantastic ensemble cast
that includes hal halbrook
adrian barbeau and jamie lee curtis it
doesn't quite have halloween's energy
but it shows carpenter and hill maturing
as horror storytellers and it's a
masterpiece in its own right
the last film in carpenter's
thematically linked apocalypse trilogy
and the mouth of madness is both a
tribute to horror writer hp lovecraft
and carpenter's exploration of the often
frightening links between fiction and
reality
the film follows an insurance
investigator who's tasked with tracking
down a best-selling horror novelist
who's gone missing along with the
manuscript to his next book
his search leads him to a new england
town that's supposed to only exist on
the page but which seems to be coming to
frightening life all around him
he sees you he sees you
he sees you what
sam neil is predictably fantastic in the
lead role portraying a man who's slowly
unraveling with convincing intensity and
carpenter is clearly delighting in
showing us a lovecraftian tale of
madness and doom and all its glory
in the mouth of madness builds and
builds much like one of lovecraft's own
stories
unfolding first as a strange mystery and
then exploding into monstrous ecstasy by
the end
it may not stand tall with the very best
of carpenter's films but it's still very
good
and certainly ranks among his most
ambitious visions of horror
carpenter's second feature film is also
the first of several of his movies to
ultimately get the remake treatment as
well as the film that earned him the
kind of attention that later led to
halloween
it's also a cult masterclass on how to
do low budget suspense right
assault on precinct 13 is set almost
entirely in the titular police precinct
where a pair of cops and a pair of
administrative workers are preparing to
close up the facility entirely so the
precinct can move to a new location
before they can do that though a
traumatized man runs in looking for help
after killing a member of a local street
gang
the gang already angered by a recent
massacre of their people by the lapd
declare all-out war
and the people inside the precinct
prepare to try and survive the night as
bloodthirsty criminals close in on them
stripped down tightly plotted and full
of tense moments assault on precinct 13
is carpenter's first showcase of his
gift for suspense and inventively staged
action
all the great stuff we'd later see in
films like the thing and the fog exist
in an early form here
and it still holds up more than 40 years
later
carpenter's best attempt at pure sci-fi
adventure arrived in 1981
when he and co-writer nick castle
dreamed up a new future in which the
island of manhattan has been converted
into a super prison where the prisoners
set up their own twisted version of
society
they also dreamed up one of the most
memorable anti-heroes in genre movie
history
kurt russell's snake pliskin you gonna
kill me now snake
i'm too tired
maybe later escape from new york is set
up with a relatively simple action movie
premise
snake has 22 hours to go into manhattan
and rescue the president of the united
states if he fails
he dies what makes escape such an
engrossing memorable film is all in the
journey
as carpenter lays out in constantly
engaging details a way in which a new
world has been built among the ruins of
old manhattan
as snake encounters character after
character we get a clearer picture of
what his weird mirror image of society
has become
all culminating in his encounter with
the duke of new york funny
and genius and beautifully realized
escape from new york still ranks among
the great dystopian films
carpenter followed up starman in 1986
with big trouble in little china
another film he didn't write but hoped
to use as a platform to prove that he
was more than just the horror guy
this time carpenter hoped to translate
his love of kung fu movies into his own
work and the result is a film that is
both
very different from the surrounding
movies in his filmography and also
indicative of the same kind of swagger
he displayed with they live and escape
from new york
of course if you want to make a film
with swagger having kurt russell along
for the ride never hurts
in his fourth collaboration with
carpenter russell shines as jack burton
a trucker who's roped into an unexpected
supernatural conflict among two very old
chinese factions
russell's in over his head action hero
style is what anchors the film but
carpenter is also clearly having a blast
through the various scenes of magical
martial arts mayhem
there's a reason big trouble in little
china continues to find new audiences
it might contain more pure popcorn fun
than any other carpenter flick
though he's mostly thought of as a
horror master carpenter's made almost as
many classic films in the realm of
science fiction as he has in that of
pure scares
often overlapping the two to great
effect they live as more sci-fi than
horror but carpenter also turned all of
his creature feature powers on for the
story of an every man wanderer who comes
upon a pair of sunglasses that reveal to
him the terrible truth about the world
that humanity is being subliminally
controlled by horrific aliens and human
disguises
our impulses are being redirected
we are living in an artificially induced
state of consciousness
that resembles sleep roddy piper best
known at the time as a wrestler is
fantastic in the role of nada and
watching him go toe-to-toe with keith
david sprang throughout the film is
great fun
the alien ghouls at the center of the
conspiracy in the film are at various
points terrifying and hilarious
sometimes walking the line between those
extremes to great effect
what really sets they live apart as a
cult classic though is that it's
carpenter's most finely tuned piece of
social commentary
the anti-consumerist allegories he's
working with are not too subtle but he
hits every note with savage perfection
it's a wickedly gleeful gem of a movie
halloween is the stuff of indie
filmmaking legend made with just three
hundred thousand dollars on a very short
schedule
and starring a then relatively untested
jamie lee curtis the film ultimately
became one of the most profitable movies
ever made and launched a franchise
that's still kicking more than 40 years
later
it also reshaped the horror genre for
decades to come
though there are certain elements of its
diy production style that can still be
nitpicked today halloween is that rare
horror film that actually lives up to
all the hype
even if you're watching it for the first
time decades after it was first released
carpenter and co-writer producer deborah
hill do so much with so little
crafting a spooky little world in
haddonfield illinois and then filling it
with characters we truly like
only to wrap the knots of tension around
their necks and tighten them until they
snap
from the opening steadicam shot to those
final ominous moments halloween remains
a landmark film that is often imitated
but very very rarely matched
a research station in the middle of
nowhere a group of men in way over their
heads and an alien organism that can
take the form of anything it touches
with often gruesome results
these are the elements that launch john
carpenter's grand masterpiece
a film so thick with paranoia and so
packed with awesome gore effects that no
matter how many times you've seen it
you somehow always end up in the edge of
your seat you're gonna have to sleep
sometime mccoody
real light sleeper child there are so
many things to love about the thing
carpenter's love story to sci-fi
creature features but the thing most
people gravitate to right away is visual
effects master rob botean's otherworldly
creature effects
the film is packed with unforgettable
moments of gore and mutated mayhem
from defibrillator paddles disappearing
into a chest to a severed head growing
legs and antennae and scuttling off into
the darkness
carpenter takes to directing these
sequences with a natural flare but his
talon for suspense particularly shines
in the moments between the gore
the scene in which mccready ties his
friends up so he can test their blood
one by one is a masterful exercise in
paranoid tension
as is the film's apocalyptic final scene
it's a brilliant exercise in terror from
start to finish
and the brightest spot in a filmography
full of great genre work
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you